what advice do you have for those that
want to be building a life that's built
to last once they start experiencing
massive success once now there are
different things coming their way
stewarding success is crushing a lot of
content
creators how can we guard against that I
think there's a couple things I'd like
to maybe highlight one is that um
Fame wealth power success they're all
wonderful outcomes I don't want to
diminish them they're just terrible
intentions when you make Fame your
purpose you will collapse even if you
become famous because you'll never be
famous enough because it's an elusive
endgame if you make wealth your purpose
you will collapse under the weight of
that wealth because wealth is a brutal
purpose because you'll never be wealthy
enough and you'll always have the fear
of not
having but when it's an outcome it's a
wonderful thing and I I know so many
people who had incredible wealth and
they lost it all and they would say well
I I lost my purpose well that's because
your purpose was in the outcome your
purpose should be about becoming your
purpose should always be rooted in the
person you're becoming not and what you
accomplish and when your purpose is
rooted when who you're becoming whether
you succeed or fail that doesn't touch
your purpose it's just an outcome
differential that you can change over
time and then I think the thing is it's
why I wrote mind shift because I I I
realized even last night I was doing
this book signing at uh the Grove at
Barnes & Noble in LA and sometimes you
explain something and you see it for the
first time and I realize that I've been
in three major phases of My Life as a
mentor and the first I spent it with the
urban poor I worked with gangbangers
drug cartels people who are incredibly
impoverished and I went with I went in
with a very idealistic view of humanity
I thought if I can just remove the
obstacles that are keeping them trapped
in poverty they all they will all just
rise up but I was wrong there were
internal structures of failure in their
mental thinking the mental constructs
their mental mind mindsets that actually
held them back and then I thought okay
that's why the poor are being held back
so if I can change their mental
structures if I can give them a mind
shift I can move them out of poverty
that's 10 years then I moved to LA and
started working with artists creativ you
know the the most intuitive people in
the world the more most creative people
in the world and I thought they're going
to be different and I realized oh my
gosh they have the same mental structure
issues that the poor had and even though
they're hyper creative and Hyper
artistic and no matter how much
celebrity they gain they're still
struggling with depression they're still
struggling with a lack of value they're
still struggling with identity issues
they are still struggling with the exact
same negative structures that the people
trapped in poverty were that was the
next 20 years of my life and then I
started working with people who were
from the hundred millions to the
billions
and I thought okay it's going to be
different here I got to find a new game
plan right you know I need I need a new
skill set for my advising coaching and
it didn't take five minutes before I
realized oh my gosh this guy has a
billion dollars he has the exact same
mental structures as the creative and
the exact same mental structures as the
guy who's poor and if they don't change
those mental structures they're going to
be rich and miserable they're going to
have billions and die alone they're not
going to have any friendships they're
going to wake up every day with a sense
of sadness and depression and so I wrote
mind shift because I realized that most
people have strategies to deal with
failure but very few people have
strategies for dealing with success and
while some of us may fall under the
weight of failure most of us who are
listening are going to collapse under
the weight of success and we don't plan
for Success we think we do but we don't
we don't sit down and go what kind of
human being do I need to be to carry a
100 million what kind of human being do
I need to be to lose a 100 million and
then get back up and start all over
again because I have several friends who
have done that what kind of mental
structures do I need if I I had I met
with a guy my first meeting with him I
got an email would you meet with this
guy and I said sure Friday coffee I
didn't know he lived in New York he
jumped on a plane came and met me for
coffee had lost $2
billion from his company and 55 million
from his personal account and had a
heart attack got up to 270 pounds his
marriage was in
Ruins and I always get people oftentimes
at that stage of the game and was really
facing some tremendous issues and I
realize he's struggling with the same
need for a mind shift that the gang
banger was dealing with that highly
successful creative artist who everyone
sees as a celebrity was dealing with
yeah and you know we' become really
great friends it's been a 5-year journey
together you know he just settled for
$4.2 billion doesn't have a single
single bit of debt in his entire life
owns like 20 companies his marriage has
been healed his family is doing
fantastic wow but it's not because he
figured out how to be a better
businessman it's because he dealt with
the internal structures that would lead
to to self destructive Behavior yeah our
greatest enemy is not taking care of our
inner world and that's why the opening
page of the book says the intention of
this book is to destroy internal
limitations because the only real
limitations that will ever hold us back
are within our own mental structures if
you enjoy this podcast and are ready for
some deep dive YouTube strategy just go
to think masterclass.com to get access
to my 1hour on demand YouTube strategy
class you'll be looking over my shoulder
as I share my best tips and you can
watch it on Demand right now at think
masterclass.com